hello everyone welcome
um yeah
yeah closer to the mic I have a mic
right here okay I guess I just need to
speak louder I'll try
okay
sorry
yeah my talk today is level up your
wrist skills from Nepal lip to all of
this uh we will talk a little bit about
my pal lib and then how we build from
map our lab to all of us you can find my
slides through this link is on my GitHub
pages
so let's get started
most of you probably don't know me my
name is Sophia my background is in
psychology statistics and computer
science I have been working in Anaconda
for more than four years I contribute to
all of us and a few other open open
source python project
I also have a data science machine
learning book club if you're interested
in joining a book club
um yeah so the reason why I'm talking
about all of us today is because I'm an
avid user of Hollywood's Tools in my
data science workflow I actually need to
build a lot of plots and visualization
that's why I fell in love with all of
this and starting contributing to all of
this so I want to share with you my love
and hopefully you will get to know more
about all of this
um my python visualization journey is
actually starting from Nepal live uh
everyone I know everyone probably have
heard and uh used Maple lip right it's
one of the first python libraries that I
have used and fell in love with uh it is
actually a very powerful tool that a lot
of new users probably have not figured
that out but it's actually powerful you
can probably
reproduce any kind of static plots you
see on the internet on map Outlet
using some magic and some effort
hopefully uh here's the anatomy of a map
of little figure where you have a figure
which controls all the elements you see
here and then the map figure includes
one or two one more axes and then you
can Define all the elements in the axis
and do your plotting again it's a very
powerful tool you can pretty much
configure every single element in your
figure and it's it can also render to a
lot of different formats like PDF PNG
SVG and all the other formats that's why
it's well loved by academics I know Tom
just mentioned this in his talk mapa lab
is actually used by 17 of the papers
today note that the papers is not just
python papers it's all the papers are
archived so it's actually quite
impressive
um yeah so Shameless plug if you are
interested in learning more about my pal
lip
um I recently created a course called
introduction to python visualization
with with an introduction to data
visualization with python using map
Olive and uh
panda style plot and Seaborn you can
click on this link to go to the page
yeah
so
here's my slides again
um
yeah so
why am I talking about holidays right so
as I was working with data more and more
in my everyday data science job I
realized I started to using a lot more
high level open source tools built on
top of my palette and some other uh open
source Library such as bokeh and I
realized that I have three needs in
terms of my visualization uh first of
all I am quite lazy I want to write as
little code as possible and if I don't
need to write any code to explore my
data that's even better
and suddenly I want my plots to be
interactive uh
I know my problem can also give you
interactive uh GUI and uh plots but it's
not built on JavaScript it's not
designed to be interactive in the
browser Tom can correct me if I'm wrong
uh so that's my second need that I want
my plot to be interactive uh the third
need I have is I need to build a
dashboard when we deliver develop
deliverables to stakeholders we normally
need to deliver a dashboard and in this
dashboard I want to include different
types of plots whether it's map outlib
or bokeh or some other plots I want the
flexibility in my dashboard
so uh and then I realized all of us can
uh pretty much satisfy all my needs uh
holidays is developed developed and
created by three of my friends and
co-workers uh Jim Bender Philip rudiger
and John Luke Stevens uh just sponsored
and supported by anaconda and many other
uh fundings it is completely open source
so uh yeah if you want to contribute to
Carlos uh that would be awesome
hollowess is a python realization
ecosystem it's not just one package it's
actually eight packages in this talk
we'll mostly talk about the first two
panel and HV plot panel is a tool for
you to build a dashboard so when we talk
about a whole of its dashboard we're
actually talking about a panel dashboard
HP plot is the entry point for you to
build a hollowess plots
um entry plot also works with all the
other tools in this ecosystem for
example HP plot works with datashader in
the back end to do big data
visualization we'll talk about that in a
little in a little bit yeah
so here here are all the topics I want
to talk about
um all of us today uh we want to start
from the basic syntax we'll talk about
how do you switch between multiple
back-ends for your plus and then we'll
talk about how to explore your data
using HP plug Explorer how do we do big
data visualization how do we do
streaming day like visualization how to
create a dashboard and then finally how
to do a deployment
uh yeah I know it's a lot of content uh
but I'll be high level so that you can
get an overview of what holloways can do
and if you want to explore more and
learn more you can read the
documentations later
so let's start from the basic syntax
here's the netplot lip syntax that many
people are familiar with right you have
a you need to create a figure which
contains a single Axis or multiple axis
is and then uh you can plot your data on
the axis and set different attributes of
your axis
note that here I'm plotting a pandas
data frame we call it DF with column X
and Y oftentimes when I am working with
pandas data frame I am actually using uh
the pandas.plot API if I use most of the
time I use either pns data frame or Dash
data frame both both in both scenarios
you can use the Dot Plot API right it
will return you a nice looking plot and
the syntax looks quite easy you can
Define your x-axis y-axis in order all
the other attributes of the plot
for entry plot um
yeah if you're familiar with pandas the
apply API uh you're probably find it
really easy to transition to
um entry plot because you can just
change.plot2.hpplot and of course you
need to import the needed modules like
on HP plot.pandas for pandas data frame
uh you can do hpcloud.dash for dash data
frame it also works with uh Rapids XL
Ray and many other data formats and it's
all the same same syntax
so the default of HP plot is actually
bokeh that's why the plug you see here
is a bokeh plot here's the bokeh logo
where you can zoom and pan using those
icons what if you want to get a Napa lip
plot using a tree plot uh yes you can so
again the default is bokeh but if you
define if you add the Slime
hvplot.extension map.lib you will return
a map lip plot for you and if you want
to have a bloody plot simply do it at
the Slime HV plot or extension probably
you will get a poly plot right so it's
super super convenient you use the same
same tags and get different styles of
plots
um yeah
and then the next thing which I love a
lot is x-ray play explore uh a lot of
the times when I work with new data I
actually don't know what I want to plot
I just kind of want to see everything uh
so with each replay explore you just
need to write this one love code
hvplot.explore parenthesis DF
um and then you get this dashboard where
you can Define what's the the type of
plot you want to get what is the x-axis
what's the y-axis what's the group by
variables right so it's super convenient
way for you to to to Define your plot
and uh yeah and of course you can add
the title labels and styles and others
uh yeah this is the tool I absolutely
love
um don't need you do not you don't need
to know how to how to code to use this
tool I just want that of code and after
you've found a good plot that you love
with this dashboard you can call a plot
on a score code to get the the code for
for this plot so this code will give you
the the code of the current state of the
dashboard right so if you want to copy
and paste this code to your YouTube
notebook and use it later it will help
you reproduce this plot later
okay uh the next thing I want to talk
about is Big Data visualization
um to the left here we have pandas.plot
API plotting 11 million data points of
New York City Taxi data we plot the
drop-off locations the latitude and
longitude and it is a scatter plot
notice that it is just as blob it's
really hard to extract meaningful
information from this plot I know some
of you might think okay what if about
what if I just add a alpha value to
increase the transparency I've tried
that it still doesn't look very good so
with HP plot you can see with a few
lines of code you can get a really
meaningful plot really easily and really
fast you can see where the where exactly
in New York you get the high density of
traffic data and where you get less data
right
um the magic of this big data
visualization licing this one line of
code rasterize equals true uh where each
reply use data Shader to apply
rasterization basically Aggregate and
counts your data and putting to cancel
data for each pixel of your figure and
it uses number it's uh
compile cell code to C code that's to to
machine code that's why it's like super
fast to give you the result back and of
course we applied the histogram
Equalization as the normalization method
for this plot you can also do a log or
linear method to see which whichever you
think works that works the best for your
figure
and then you can define the color map
which is the pretty color we have we
have here
um from dark to red and to White
and then for tiles
um tiles defines the underlying Earth
image so that we can overly overlay your
plot on top of the tiles
any questions so far sorry let me drink
some water yes
yes exactly yeah
foreign
okay so there are actually multiple ways
to make this plot you can also uh have
the tiles defined separately and overlay
your plots um the tiles figure
um it's all okay and uh
yeah so that's big data optimization
uh the next is streaming data
visualization uh where entry plot
supports streams
um data frames so to on the top here we
have a function returning a this is just
a pandas data frame of your computer
memory usage uh information right so the
magic is this function periodical data
frame where we fading this memory data
function and ask it to return a record
for us every 300 milliseconds and the
returning DF here is not a pan of data
frame anymore it's a streams data frame
but HP plot works for the streams the
data frame the same way it works for the
any other data frames or just do DF and
here I have the columns which is the
used memory memory
um and we I plotted a line plot and
showing 200 records of this data and his
data streams data streaming data
real-time data really easily
okay next important thing is dashboard
right
um I'm going to show you how exactly to
build this dashboard in a second so uh
there are actually
uh sorry three ways to build a panel
dashboard so you can if you click on
this link you can get to my blog post
um which tell you the three ways I
should be plot down interactive piano
binding Ram those are the three main
ways there are also other ways to build
a dashboard uh it depends on your your
needs and each of them gets more complex
and handles more complex situations and
uh in this blogs post I show you how to
build this one dashboard with three
methods so you can compare the code if
you want
okay so
um
in this talk I mostly want to talk about
HP plot.interactive how to convert your
pandas data processing pipeline into a
panel dashboard to the left here we have
a pandas data processing pipeline where
we give it a name called Pipeline and
it's actually returning a data frame
where we use the data frame of the car
manufacturer data and we substitute this
data frame by the number of cylinders
manufacturer of their data and we
calculate the horsepower for each origin
and miles per gallon and then the
returning data frame looks like this
this is the five first five records you
can see the value of the average
horsepower for each origin and each
Mouse per gallon for your car
to make this path line interactive uh so
here are the code uh you can you can do
df.interactive to make your data frame a
HP plot interact an interactive HP plot
data data frame and then you can define
an interactive pipeline where instead of
defining actual values of your
um the actual values here you can just
using panel widgets to manipulate the
values you want to add here for example
we have cylinders which is a slider you
can you can choose the number of Sliders
either here and the manufacturer and
also the y-axis is available we're
interested in to calculate average on
those are grouped button groups so you
can choose different values in your
wages and I will show you different
results so it's quite
quite easy right
okay let me show you a demo very quick
so
so if you click on this link
um it goes to a GitHub page where I have
all the all the files here on the main I
also have a blog post here if you want
to read more the main file we are
looking at is a tree plot interactive
file here I open it up in my Jupiter
notebook
yeah so this is what we said before
first of all we make the data frame
interactive and then we make panel
widgets here I can show you how the
widgets look
um so the senders you can choose four
eight six because we start from four
ended eight and step is two so it's
basically just giving us three values
and then if you want to take a look at
manufacturer you can choose
different things in y-axis that you
choose between horsepower and weight
and then we combine the piplier widget
to make an interactive pipeline uh where
you can change different values and then
to
uh and then here we pipe it to a good
looking table where you can sort your
table
um by by different columns so you can
see different pages so this is just a
better view for your table
and then similarly we can do dot in dot
entry plot as we have a
we have seen earlier it's the exactly
same syntax but it also works on the
interactive Pipeline and interactive
data frame and the resulting plot is
Interactive
quite interesting right
s and horsepower
and then finally I use the template to
have my widgets in the sidebar and have
my plot and table showing in the main
content and then to serve this notebook
we can run
um panel serve
panel serve will
serve your Noble locally
and why is it not loading
that's weird
sorry
why is not defined
I swear you just worked a little bit
earlier
fake demo
yeah it must be somewhere like I added a
y somewhere
huh
I am so sorry about this I swear it
wasn't breaking
a minute earlier
okay
this looks missing
okay yeah I don't know what's going on
okay you can round
um
template.show it will just uh show up as
a separate page if we want to serve it
we actually need to do panels serve I
should return the same thing
yeah
I don't know it should work
anyways you get the idea
uh
I'll make sure it's fixed I think if you
if you clone the repo and run it in your
own environment it should work
okay so that's deployment I just talked
about panel serve which is
uh you can you can it doesn't it does
not only work with your Jupiter notebook
file but also works with your python
file uh Standalone python file so
um you gotta write your app in either
way and the final thing I want to talk
about is
that panel allow you to convert to app
to
um a pile Die app or a typescript app
super easily if you have uh went to the
fabulous talk this morning about Pi
script you'll want to say a little bit
about how Pi Square Works in in your
browser so this allows you to to run
your panel dashboard in a browser
without any server needed
so what you need is panel convert and
then convert your app to a to awesome
so
in so hopefully this would work
we simply run panel convert and your
file you can use power die worker to run
power die in the in a in a separate
thread if you don't have power networker
just do pile die you will run powder in
the main thread and then you can output
the files into a separate file called
docs right here and we look at docs it
will generate a HTML file for you and
also a Javascript file the Javascript
file only show up where we have a power
die worker in a separate thread that
handles the the separate worker
Okay so
so once we push that to our document
um
uh we can set up GitHub pages
from the docs and then and then you can
just you can see the app showing up on
GitHub pages
as you can see
um as we're loading the page this uh the
GitHub page is actually uh downloading
all the needed packages and executing
the code in the browser it's not running
on any server so this means that you can
build any of your panel apps and put it
up on your own web page or GitHub pages
so it's super easy for you to share your
dashboard with the word
and then you can see you can change
different things and make your dashboard
Interactive
um
yeah so that's that uh the fun the final
thing I want to share with you is the
awesome panel.org
where we can see some examples of
the panel dashboard
so if you don't want to use panel
convert and do the Jupiter do the GitHub
Pages you can use panel or panel
awesomepanel.org where you write your
own app and it will convert to a web
page for you you can log in with your
GitHub page and you can host your your
app on this on this website it's built
by a Community member
um of all of this uh it's quite nice and
if you go to the gallery uh you can see
I have uploaded
some demo here and uh
you can do a lot of powerful things with
with panel and with um
with the power die in pi script for
example uh here's an example where you
can use your video stream to detect your
face and do some facial detections
so here you can do different things and
you can do facial detection
yeah and and this also works on GitHub
pages
yeah if you want to learn more about
Halloween
make sure to check out hollywoods.org
which will include a more lengthy
tutorial for you to go through or check
out the official documentations
panel.holidays.org and HP plot all of us
and if you have any questions go to
discourse.holidays.org the core
developers will be there to help you
thank you any questions
[Applause]
so I've spent many hours trying to
program like the custom JavaScript and
bokeh
um so if you wanted to customize your
interactions is that you can travel
scripture
um yeah both you if you want to have
your customized JavaScript embedding
panel you can do that
yeah if you search panel JavaScript
there should be a page of examples for
you
yes
I've probably looked at some of the
alternative
Botley Dash
yeah that's a great question uh let me
direct you to my blog post I wrote a
blog post about that uh let me see
please
yep
so this blog post is based on the
well the the panel talks given by all
the core developers from different
packages uh you can see here is the
table of all the comparisons for four of
the uh the libraries for dashboarding
we'll have the dash panel voila and
streamlit
um so the the main difference are
yeah that's your tool support your
favorite product Library uh streamlined
and piano supports many uh and if you
use Jupiter notebooks Panna and voila
supports Japan notebooks if you need to
build complex apps and use Big Data
piano and dash do that uh if you need a
lot of simultaneous users Dash skills
the best and if you want to share your
app with the public streamnet provides
easy deployment but now I think almost
every app allow you to deploy to the
browser now so it's all pretty easy
deployment
I think I'm going to follow you on
thank you
any other questions
yes yes is obvious my sister does too
yeah
I'm quite proud of the cat picture
selections I have here
yeah
yeah I mean I think this one's cool
yes
um so you can do face detection can you
do like any custom intervision model
that's a great question uh
the the bottleneck neck is a pie torch
that's a wrong
um pile die yet so you need to have high
script running on power dye first in
order to have things running smoothly I
mean pie torch is it's hard it's on pile
die but pied horse depends on so many
other libraries so it won't run
so hopefully you will come soon
oh now he works
yeah I don't know why it did not work
before yeah now it doesn't have any
error message
okay
it's a working demo now sorry about that
thank you bye
[Applause]